the british and french governments have
vowed to go after people traffickers
after two children aged five and eight
were among four people who died
when a migrant boat sank off the coast
of france my teams the uk coast guard
agency
and the national crime agency have been
in close contact with the french
we've offered our assistance both with
the investigative response
and the search and rescue effort today's
tragic events just seek to underline
the risks that facilitators are prepared
to go to to risk migrants lives for
profits
and strengthens our resolve to go after
them and bring them to justice
well mark white is in dunkirk for us now
so mark what's the latest on the search
and rescue operation
well that search and rescue operation
which was taking place just two
kilometers
offshore from this port was ended as
darkness descended on the english
channel
now it will resume again in the morning
because authorities simply don't know
for sure how many people were on board
this bulls it's not like a ferry people
obviously aren't buying tickets to get
on these
little tiny boats so it's really up to
those people that were on board the
boats themselves
to give that kind of information to the
authorities but they will have been
very shaken up by their ordeal some of
them still
in hospital suffering the effects of the
cold that
they received having been in the english
channel the prime minister said
it is a very serious and disturbing
incident he's offered the french
authorities
all the assistance that they need in the
uh
investigation going forward but it is
notoriously difficult
to try to go after these people
smugglers it's a sophisticated
operation and the very worrying thing is
that
unlike previous years when this migrant
boat activity would cease in the winter
months
now that activity is continuing into the
winter months
in terrible conditions out there in the
english channel and that is of great
concern